I'm super frustrated with TikTok this morning.
Like, just heartened frustrated.
I post homesteading, home making,
home schooling videos, and my niche is cooking from scratch.
Like, extreme scratch.
Like, I start off with the animal on my homestead
and throughout the video get to a cooked meal.
And for the most part, people love my videos.
I get millions of views. Um,
my videos often go viral
and every single one of my videos only gets reported. Um,
even though I don't show the dispatcher of any animal
or show any stress of an animal or abuse of an animal,
my videos reported. Normally I just appeal the video, um,
because the violation is for animal abuse.
And since there is no animal abuse,
my video gets put back up and everyone gets to enjoy it.
Except my, um,
two or three videos back, I just got a violation. Um,
bear in mind the same footage is used in several videos. Um,
it shows me putting a chicken into a place where it's called a cone. Um,
dispatch cone, I guess you'd say.
Obviously doesn't show what I do there. Um,
which is, you know,
ending the chicken. Doesn't show that.
It shows right after it. There's no blood.
You don't see any of that stuff.
You don't see any of the stuff you don't wanna see.
Most people have it just pop up on your FYP page.
Do not wanna see that part,
which I understand you are Free to scroll along.
But, you know,
some people just wanna have to tell me or report me.
That's not something they wanna see.
And with the guidelines, you cannot post that,
even though it would be very educational.
But I understand why. So this time I.
I pulled the video decision and it got denied.
So that video that I worked really hard on was totally wiped off.
I deleted it because I cannot speak to anyone from TikTok shop,
TikTok at all when I put in a ticket.
And I wanna report, I wanna report
there's an issue. I wanna.
I wanna speak to somebody about why this video.
Like what.
What was so different about this video?
Even though it was up for nearly a week,
it doesn't have any issues.
It doesn't show anything that any of my other video show.
I'm very careful how I edit.
I'm not just, you know,
oh, I'm missing something.
Like, I'm not missing anything.
But then you go to report and then it won't send the.
They just says not sent. Every time I go to chat,
it's not sent. Every time I put in a ticket,
not sent it.
TikTok is literally refusing for me to speak to them right now.
I've restarted the app, I've redownloaded the app,
I've logged in, logged out.
It's just I cannot put a ticket in
to understand
or speak to somebody about why my content has been deleted.
Yeah, it's not On the Creator Rewards program anymore.
I really don't care. It's not about that.
It's the principle of it.
That I can spend all my time making these videos that people like.
People actually like my content.
It's not just something I'm just like,
oh, yeah,
like, it's just something I wanna do.
People in. This is educational stuff.
People wanna know how to cook from scratch.
People wanna know how to process a chicken.
People wanna understand what they're eating.
You know, it just feels like another way that.
I don't like to be cliche,
but the government can control your food.
Like, the local government,
the state government,
and the federal government do not like people making their own food.
And I just got something to do with it.
I don't know. I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
but I'm just tryna share the knowledge
of how you can easily raise your own meat.
And you're not required to be part of the government food chain.
You can take back control.
You can learn the skills that your ancestors knew,
and it's very easy. Um,
we're desensitized to creating our own meat as a society.
Many other cultures still do it this way,
and if you look into it, these cultures don't have as many diseases
and health problems as we do.
Most of my comments on my videos are just, oh,
this is on my. Why is this on my FYP page?
While I'm eating chicken nuggets?
Or While I'm eating Popeyes,
it's just funny. People find it amusing.
People have their eyes, like,
awoken to it. They. Yeah,
most people for most people ever wanna know
because that is very educational and they want to know.
Other people are just like,
have not even all about where their food comes from,
and this is just like a wake up call for them.
They're just like, oh man,
this is where my food comes from.
So they find it interesting.
there's a few amount of people that get absolutely disgusted by it.
And they will let me know in my DMs,
you know, how horrible person I am,
how absolutely disgusting I am.
Even though that I care for my chickens.
They're completely free range.
They can go where they want their whole lives
up until about five minutes before their life has ended.
Very swiftly, I pick them up,
I hold onto them, I calm them down,
I put them in the cone, and then they're dispatched very swiftly.
They don't know what's coming,
they don't feel any pain.
Because it's done so swiftly that there's no more pain receptors.
Um, there's no,
you know, they're not heads,
not attached to their body anymore,
so there's no way of them feeling that.
Chickens flap around a lot,
that's why they're in the cone. Um,
and that's just how they are.
Because the nerves and energy still in their body,
they're not alive anymore.
So we Use the cone as it's, um,
an easier way to do it. They're not flapping around everywhere.
There's no huge stress to us or the animal.
Before it happens, they're in there and they feel in snug.
And if you know anything about chickens,
if you hold them upside down,
they kind of relax, they calm down,
they don't do anything. Um,
and they're in a relaxed state.
So if you compare that to how factory chickens are done.
They live their whole lives in these huge chicken barns, um,
that are completely packed in with chickens.
I mean, no room to. Sorry.
My kids like going through all the drawers in the kitchen.
They have no room to move around.
Um, they spend their whole life inside.
They don't even see daylight.
No fresh air, no grass to peck.
Chickens love free ranging.
They love pecking the grass,
eating the bugs and just being free.
And then they're swiftly ended.
And these are normally Cornish cross.
They only live for about. I think it's nine weeks.
Could be wrong on that one.
I think it's nine weeks. Um,
if you let them grow any longer than that,
they get tumors, cancer.
Their legs can't hold them up,
their organs fail
because they are genetically engineered to just grow breasts.
So their breasts will start hanging on the ground.
Um, they'll drag their bodies around.
Pretty much they'll just lay around.
They have hardly any feathers.
Um, they have a Pretty disgusting existence.
So people to tell me that what I'm doing is disgusting,
but then again, they eat Popeyes,
Chick fil A, then that's disgusting.
Anyway, I would like to continue to share my knowledge
of the way that I produce food
in my own home and share that with you.
Um, and if anyone else would like to share a lot,
enjoy my education, then please follow.
Um, right now my videos are pretty much shadowbanned,
so not getting many views,
but, you know,
I'm happy to share my knowledge
and continue to get past this point on TikTok
and continue with my account.
I also have a great blog that I started, um,
that I've been wanting to start for so many years.
And my recent test on TikTok has made me
inspired me to get back into it,
so I'm on there. Um,
I have more detailed instructions on how to process and cook
and some recipes to go along with it.
So I'm here, so hopefully you enjoy it.